it's hard to imagine anything more
transformative in american history than
the civil war before the civil war the
united states was a largely rural barely
unified collection of states not making
much of a blip on the world stage after
the civil war the united states was well
on its way toward becoming a modern
country with a strong central government
and a thriving industrial economy that
was soon to make it into a serious world
power the civil war is seen as such an
enormous turning point in u.s history
that most colleges split courses into
u.s history before 1865 and u.s history
after 1865. but was the united states
really that different before and after
the civil war as historians we could
tackle that question from a lot of
different angles we could look at the
role of the federal government in
american life before and after the war
we could look at changes in the economy
i'm curious about changes in american
national identity during this period
what do i mean by national identity
national identity encompasses things
like core beliefs about democracy
citizenship and america's proper role in
the world we can identify these beliefs
in different time periods by looking at
practices like who gets to vote which
groups are defined as a part of the
american people versus which groups are
defined as aliens or others and whether
the american public is expressing lots
of national pride or lots of doubt about
the way things are going so now we've
got a historical question that we're
curious about if we saw the question
like this on an exam it might say
something like compare the relative
significance of the effects of the civil
war on american values okay well what
we're really doing is asking how much
did the civil war change the core
beliefs around american national
identity did it change some more than
others to answer this question first we
need to decide which core beliefs we
want to track i'm going to choose ideas
around democracy so who gets to vote
whether americans believe that democracy
is something everyone should participate
in or just a select few second let's
look at ideas around citizenship who is
defined as an american or as part of the
american people and entitled to the
privileges and immunities of citizenship
last
let's look at ideas about america's role
in the world whether or how the united
states should be involved in world
affairs or extending its influence
beyond the boundaries of the united
states now you might want to look at
different core beliefs than i've chosen
here like maybe whether people saw their
regional identity as more important than
their national identity and if you want
to do that that's totally okay i'm gonna
go with these three themes for now so
let's brainstorm some of the major
trends that occur in each of these
themes before and after the civil war in
between 1844 and 1877. i've got our
timeline here with the big dividing line
at the end of the civil war now we're
looking at this from a bird's eye view
of the whole era so i'm not going to go
into much detail about the events we're
talking about if something sounds
unfamiliar to you just make a note of it
and you can go back to review that
concept when you have time all right
first democracy in the years before the
civil war what were the prevailing ideas
about who should be able to vote and who
actually could vote in practice well by
1844 most states had extended voting
rights to all white men regardless of
property ownership women couldn't vote
and neither could enslaved africans in
the south and voting rights for free
african american men in the north were
pretty limited how about after the civil
war well the biggest change there was
the ratification of the 15th amendment
in 1870 which granted all men the right
to vote enfranchising african-american
men it did not to the disappointment of
the women's suffrage movement in
franchise women but by 1877 the end of
reconstruction when the federal
government stopped enforcing the rights
of black citizens in the south jim crow
laws would make voting all but
impossible for black men okay now let's
look at how values around citizenship
changed before and after the civil war
who was a citizen before the civil war
and who was considered eligible to be
part of the american people well white
men definitely and white women free
people of color in the north with some
limitations depending on their state of
residence immigrants arriving from
ireland and germany were eligible for
citizenship but native americans were
considered to be members of separate
nations not americans mexican americans
and the territories acquired in the
mexican session were technically
american citizens but had few legal
protections and enslaved people in the
south were still considered property not
citizens how did that change after the
civil war well the emancipation
proclamation in 1863 and the 13th
amendment in 1865 ended slavery the 14th
amendment in 1868 made all people born
or naturalized in the united states
citizens granting citizenship to
african-american men and women in the
south but again the end of
reconstruction and the rise of jim crow
made it difficult for them to access the
rights of citizenship after 1877. white
men and women and immigrants were still
citizens the us government began to stop
treating native americans as members of
separate nations but started classifying
them as wards of the state rather than
citizens in the west chinese immigrants
were looked upon as too different to
become citizens and they would soon be
forbidden from entering the united
states at all mexican-americans saw a
little change in their precarious status
finally how did americans view the
proper role of the united states in the
world before and after the civil war in
1844 the u.s was still practicing
isolationism to avoid entangling
alliances abroad but the ideas of
manifest destiny led to a general sense
that the united states had a divine
mission to occupy north america from
coast to coast which provided the
impetus for the mexican war and for
indian removal after the civil war both
isolationism as a foreign policy outside
north america and manifest destiny as a
foreign policy within north america
continued on as before so now let's
return to our question how much did the
civil war change american national
identity in terms of ideas about
democracy there was a definitely a big
expansion of the franchise due to the
civil war with the addition of 2 million
african-american men as new voters in
the south after the ratification of the
15th amendment but that was short-lived
the jim crow system would effectively
prevent black voters in the south from
casting ballots until the 1960s in terms
of citizenship that too was altered by
the passage of a constitutional
amendment in this case the 14th
amendment those citizenship guarantees
were also short-lived but let's not
forget the long-term importance of the
14th and 15th amendments for securing
equal rights in the 20th century even
though those rights were only on paper
during the jim crow era that paper would
eventually be very important for
expanding voting and citizenship rights
after world war ii as for ideas about
america's role in the world those didn't
change much at all the drive to expand
the borders of the united states all the
way to the pacific only intensified
after the civil war so we might answer
our question with the following thesis
statement the civil war brought on some
immediate short-term changes in american
ideals of democracy and citizenship
which would fade after the end of
reconstruction while the belief in the
divine mission of the united states to
spread across north america only
intensified in this time period even
though there was little change in the
19th century the seeds planted
immediately after the civil war would
sprout into major changes in the 20th
century what do you think how would you
weigh these pieces of evidence to draw
conclusions about how the civil war
changed american values you might come
up with a completely different thesis
statement than i did and that's
perfectly fine the important part of
thinking like a historian is to gather
evidence and then craft an argument
supported by that evidence